la atención entre francia y eeuu se
alivia tras una llamada entre manuel
macrón y joe biden en su primer
acercamiento posterior al anuncio de la
alianza august los mandatarios acordaron
una reunión presencial que se realizará
en octubre para solucionar lo que
todavía es una grave crisis diplomática
el tono de la llamada fue amistoso tras
ella tenemos la esperanza y el
presidente tiene la esperanza de que
esto sea un paso para volver a la
normalidad en la relación larga
importante y duradera que eeuu tiene con
francia friends el acuerdo le costó al
país galo la cancelación de un contrato
millonario de submarinos para australia
que ahora serán proporcionados por eeuu
algo que el ministerio de exteriores
francés está hecho de puñalada por la
espalda y que ha preocupado a la alta
diplomacia europea también irritada por
la triple alianza anglosajona
tras la conversación que han tenido esta
mañana el presidente by the end y el
presidente macro no estoy seguro de que
trabajaremos juntos
la crisis de submarinos ha supuesto un
retroceso en las relaciones del gobierno
de macrón con la nueva administración
baiden y el regreso de eeuu al
multilateralismo no obstante el primer
paso para limar asperezas ya está en
marcha el embajador francés volverá a
eeuu tras su retirada de la semana
pasada